yeah some people are just natural yeah
that's why here you know any but he
doesn't eat but at all upset you um in
the beginning it did only because my ass
is just [ __ ] cleaner yeah why it's
have you tried it like did you eat a bad
but at one point like one of the first
girls I went down her muffler was beat
up dog and it just kind of made it hard
to go on from there but you got to fight
through it go be like I know you gotta
go like we have the road [ __ ] a chance
again I went on the road with Pauly I
don't want to break this girl's heart so
I'm not gonna say her name okay but I
opened from years a years ago okay so
she could be dead by now so she's
probably okay I'm not gonna say her name
oh but I did a club in Cleveland with
Pauly Shore yeah and I was featuring for
him but I was you know I could barely do
15 minutes and I met this girl she think
I'm moving to LA and I go alright
whatever and then like six months later
she's at the Sun comedy store and we
started hanging out yeah and I was doing
La Jolla you know back so back in the
day when you did La Jolla you would stay
at the condo on the beach well I still
do I love that place it's great memories
and back but they haven't done it I
haven't been there since they refurnish
you do you go back at all I haven't been
there in like 15 years because of all
another thing it's another [ __ ] war I
have with somebody else
dude do you have had some Wars I know
let me just finish your like Germany
you've been in a lot of wars yeah I have
I fight for like don't you do like one
makeup podcast a week like with somebody
where I mean it I mean I got right now
we're trying to get Yoshida yeah you
know buddy aids me Yoshi Yoshi Yoshi did
one with Yoshi nor you wanna Norma are
good that wars over and then you had do
you have you done any more I have a
couple of wars I have Joe Coyte you did
kind of made up good well the Korean
well the Asian comics ever come back
together we don't there's no war between
me and except for Yoshi but I'm good
with everyone dr. Kim wasn't there some
Noah and I are good he's great I'm good
with more everyone probably every what
are you good with half a burn Kevin Shea
no Kevin Shay's a good guy though okay
why what happened with that that's for
another podcast okay alright podcast hey
um can I finish my story well bro yeah
so you're eating bad but no that's not
what happened okay so she goes so she
goes um I'll let me go to La Jolla with
you so great so I was there with Kelly
Kirsten chef Richards that weekend
and she bought a guitar right and during
the day she would just be in the living
room in that living room and she would
like sing her songs that she wrote but
nobody wanted to hear them it was
embarrassing me she thinks we don't
four-post yeah
the Sun is here the tree is in or
whatever what the tree are you write out
your song I don't know and I would just
be like oh that's good
you did it now I got another one no you
know I would so that night that was the
first time I made love to you know love
to the person you hated yeah I was doing
doggy style
okay uh-huh and um I smell poop and so I
need to do investigations you know I
mean because I'm a curious guy detective
yeah so you smell poop so you buy like
scent no I didn't go I didn't go head in
okay I sound like every white guy over
there and run over there
I don't there's a waft when I do
investigations on [ __ ] I don't go ahead
first okay you know me I do it from afar
yeah you know you smell test finish okay
so I'm still doing up from behind and I
take the two thumbs are you opened it
yeah and I did a little Pikachu peak
peak peak ticket a little Pikachu right
I opened it off like this and she had
one nut from the [ __ ] but a hair
dingleberry no it was a hair sticking
out of her like normal but outside the
hole okay you know your C star warmer
the style of the Jedi yeah
remember that little thing that was like
swallowing people up in the desert
yeah and they had those tentacles that
would like grab lando calrissian dragon
yeah that's what she had Oh imagine that
thing and she had oh tentacle sticking
out right but was there at the end of
the [ __ ] tentacle what was a
perfectly circle little tiny round piece
of [ __ ] right open to see what that you
know but this is what she said and I'm
not kidding here she goes I just had a
vision so I'm lifting it so I'm opening
up the package right and she goes I
television you had kids like she said
why your [ __ ] little hair with a
little brown dingleberry and I'm and she
goes I had kids right and in my head I
laughed because I go I had a vision are
going to get toilet paper and I never
that was it we drove back to LA and I
think I broke her heart organ why do I
have to get punished for her dingleberry
yeah
that's why I like vagina so I mean like
dude does [ __ ] come out of the vagina
dude I mean I there's some bad vaginas
out there there is huh
yeah guys penises right yeah I've seen
daliyah's yeah I area has a horse [ __ ]
its horsey oh my gosh but it's like why
wouldn't what else about him is it nice
the guy's a good-looking guy who loses a
lot yeah are you saying eating peanuts
no dude no I get to ride at [ __ ]
magic mom the old life right its twists
right it goes this way and this way at
the same time it's like a [ __ ]
disaster hey dude
ah yeah I get that man I mean he he's
been in some [ __ ] snatch he's been in
some snatch he's been though this
podcast before
[Music]